>>It's really cool school.
I've never gone to a
school quite like it.
>>Well, we get to design games
and play each other's games,
so instead of just doing
work, work, work all day.
>>Well, we have the basic
classes of a school,
but we gave them different names,
like math is called Code World.
Science is the Way Things Work.
>>We learn everything that
all the other schools learn.
We just learn it differently.
>>My name's Katie Salen and I
wear a couple of different hats.
One, I'm a professor at Parsons,
the New School of Design and I teach
in a program there called
Designing Technology.
I also run a nonprofit called the
Institute of Play, which is a games
and learning space where we
develop all kinds of stuff
around games and learning.
And then my last hat is, I'm
an executive director of design
at this new middle school called
Quest to Learn in New York City.
>>Quest to Learn is a new sixth grade
through twelfth grade public school
that opened in New York City
in Fall 2009, and it's a school
that has the tagline,
school for digital kids.
And all that means is that we
believe that kids can and do learn
in different ways outside of school,
often via access to digital media
and access to kind of
online community support.
And that if we know
that learning outside
of school matters a great deal
to kids' ability to learn well
in school, we have to
pay attention to that.
>>So it's a school that from
the ground up has been designed
to leverage the kind of digital
lives of kids, and it also looks
at the notion of how games
work as learning systems,
and it's developed a
pedagogical approach
that delivers what we
call game-like learning.
And all that means is
that kids are dropped
into complex challenge based context,
that they have no ability to solve
at the beginning of ten weeks.
And then that ten week
structure, what we call a mission,
is broken down into a series of
smaller challenges, that scaffold
and really engage that kid in
learning how to do something
that will allow them to
solve that complex problem.
>>In watching these games,
you realize the reason why
these games are so popular,
is they're so carefully balanced
between offense and defense.
There's so many choices,
there's so many challenges.
>>We're trying to prove that game
design can help kids think deeper
and more abstractly
about everything else.
And that we feel that the
thing about game design is
that that's this generation's
mode of discourse.
It's a fully mainstreamed art
form, just like cinema is,
but a hundred years ago, you
couldn't study cinema in a school.
Now every school has a
cinematography class,
and game design has now reached
a sort of mainstream acceptance.
It's how kids socialize,
by playing games.
>>A lot of concerns that parents
have when we start talking
about games is a concern
around competition,
and a concern around notions of
kind of incentives and rewards.
And what they get worried about
is, "Oh, there's this game stuff
where kids get addicted and all
they wanna do is get better,
better, better."
And so we've tried to strike a
balance with that to say that, "Well,
what's really awesome about that is
that kids are driven to get better."
And one thing games do do very,
very well, is they understand how
to incentivize players
to want to get better.
>>And then you have two goals, but
one of them is impossible to get to.
>>Teacher: Okay.
>>My game has two goals that
are both possible to get to.
>>So the way that our curriculum
is structured in mission
and quest based, so
it actually builds
on that trope from online gaming.
And the idea is that quests actually
get harder as you move through them,
because you're actually developing
tools and developing knowledge
and developing experiences.
And the goal is that you
actually can't move to a quest
until you've completed one prior.
They're proceeding through
some kind of challenge
and they're getting closer to some
kind of end goal, and we have found
that that's very motivating for kids,
that they know where they're at,
they know how far they've come and
they know what they need to work on.
>>Game design is not just
sitting in front of a computer
and creating a game
where somebody runs
around collecting coins or something.
Game design is all about
trial and error and figuring
out all these things that
would make a good game.
>>Two of the big ideas that kids
have been working on all year,
one is ideas of teamwork
and collaboration,
which we think is a central skill
in the twenty-first century.
Being able to not only work
together with somebody,
but to have a specific expertise
and being able to talk with someone
about that, share with
someone about that,
and kind of co-build
something together.
The second idea is around this idea
of multi-modality, of kids being able
to read and encounter text and
stories and image making in a lot
of different kinds of mediums.
>>This trimester in the
Sports for the Mind class,
which is one of the central
systems thinking classes,
where kids are making games as
a way to learn about systems,
we decided to work on a
kind of translation project.
So they're studying a story,
studying Aesop's fables,
and they're looking at, what does
it take the translate the components
of a story into a live,
three D game environment?
And so we're moving from things like
a static page, into an environment
where the kids have created
and costumed characters,
they've built sets.
And then the final
exhibition is, the kids will,
in this three D game,
perform this story live.
So it's a little bit like a virtual
theater performance of a story
that has come from a kind of
oral tradition of storytelling,
moved to a printed page, moved to
a kind of graphic novel format,
now into a three D game environment.
>>We think that design
thinking is actually a way
of looking at the world.
It's a way of looking at the world
as someone who is active in thinking
about how to solve problems,
is active in kind of analyzing
and understand how things work,
and we think that's a great stance
to have, to look at
the world generally.
So we believe these kids are
gonna grow up through work
in our school as design thinkers.
That doesn't mean that
they're all gonna go
on to be designers in
professional lives.
We would imagine and love that some
of those kids will step into roles
as wanting to be scientists,
wanting to be writers,
wanting to be musicians, you
know, wanting to be whatever.
But they still will have this
perspective on how they look
at the world, and that will inform
any discipline that they go into.
>>Well, I think at the kind of
heart of everything we're doing is,
we're trying to help kids
understand how to be in charge
of their own learning, and
continue to grow as learners
across their whole life, because we
just understand that's critically
important these days.
These kids are not gonna graduate,
enter a job and be in that job
for the rest of their lives.
They're gonna need
to be able to adapt.
They're gonna have to learn
new things constantly.
And so that's the type of learner
that we're looking to graduate.